all right let's hear from you it's time
for the Friday feedback of the week or
the Friday Feed Bag someone said it
should be called the Apple bags but that
seems a little risque for our particular
setting and audience so it is what it is
but let's start with a very important
message from John McCullough who said on
YouTube David pakman drinks Bud Light
and it shows I'm going to tell you the
funniest thing about this whole Bud
Light thing now for some of you who
don't know Bud Light is now being
subjected to a boycott attempt by the
very people who say you shouldn't do
boycotts because it's a form of
cancellation Bud Light did a partnership
with Dylan Mulvaney Dylan Mulvaney is a
trans woman who I had never heard of
until conservatives got all angry about
her I I don't even know whether we would
know who Dylan Mulvaney is were it not
for right Wingers who are Furious so
after Bud Light did this partnership
with Dylan Mulvaney many on the right
said we now have to boycott Bud Light
now here's the funny thing I've been
boycotting Bud Light since I started
drinking alcohol because I think Bud
Light is terrible I think it's just
disgusting completely disgusting give me
an Allagash White give me a Belgian
wheat give me come on guys please but I
think Bud light's disgusting so when
this entire thing happened I was able to
take the position that I will continue
not having Bud Light for no reason other
than I think it's absolutely disgusting
and terrible beer the funny thing is the
following before the Dylan Mulvaney
thing when someone like me would say uh
Bud Light is terrible get me a micro
brew get me whatever
the right Wingers would go oh yeah
drink an American beer drink Bud drink
Coors drink whatever
now those very same people say Bud Light
is the one that's for the sissies who
support the the trans people or whatever
the case may be uh I have not had a Bud
Light in decades I continue not to drink
Bud Light but it is laughable that that
now counts as an insult but it just
reminds you about the strange bedfellows
and enemies that politics makes when
your brain can be so easily broken all
right another comment from kbj about the
economy kbj says to me how's Biden
working out for you bud I'm sure prices
of everything are down and the economy
is perfect right well I mean let's talk
it through Biden's working out fine for
me but I don't really need anything at
this point from the government
um the question is what does the economy
look like prices
when you look at inflation inflation
numbers are down down dramatically from
where they were a year ago so inflation
is slowing down significantly the
economy is never perfect we still have
an equality we have people who have to
work multiple jobs just like we did
under Trump and just like we did under
you know pretty it's not unique under
Obama we had that Obama under George W
bush Etc but it's hard to find
indicators that look particularly bad
the stock market is like pretty okay
unemployment is at record lows job
creation is doing well inflation's
coming down consumer confidence is doing
well a GDP has been on the upswing you
tell me I mean like point to the
indicators tell me the metrics that show
us that everything is terrible
Flawless P wrote in about book bands and
says so when told not to teach from the
Bible as though it were fact is not
teacher being censored unfairly
are you Banning books
LMAO your argument is cringe and useless
of course some topics and framing of
some topics topics aren't appropriate
for public schools that's not
controversial
I have to admit I have no idea whether
this person is in favor or against the
book Banning that we're seeing in
Florida I can't tell they say something
about the Bible when told not to teach
from the Bible as though it were fact is
a teacher being censored unfairly
is that banning a book no oh I see the
point listen there's two different
things here
saying that religious texts have no
place in science class is not Banning
books it's saying this is a science
class and religious texts of any kind
have no place here it could be the Quran
it could be the Bible it could be
whatever scientologists read or believe
in or you know the golden tablets of
Joseph Smith it that's not Banning books
it's saying those books should be in
courses about comparative religion or
history of religion this is a very
confused person who as often is the case
is taking really strong positions about
things they don't understand even
remotely and that's really the tragedy
good looking man
Rodin
commented on YouTube
and it I guess is trying to make a point
about the the tendency towards violence
of people based on whether they're
left-wing or right-wing good looking man
says wear a Maga hat through New York
City and see how far you get before you
get canceled now where it's the wrong
where where and I love Biden hat through
Florida and you'll find that you'll be
perfectly safe you know I have been
places in New York City
where some clown comes through with a
Maga hat no one pays attention to them
to him I should say I've only ever seen
guys do it it the the funny thing about
this is this person wants us to believe
that in Florida with an Isle of Biden
hat you're fine you're safe but if you
wear a Maga hat in New York City you'll
get quote canceled but he's using that
in quotes to suggest almost like it's
going to be violence you won't be safe
I've been at bars I've been at outdoor
Terraces I've been in different places
where there's a dude usually between 22
and 28 years old wearing a Maga hat and
looking super pleased with himself like
he's doing something extraordinarily
clever no one pays attention to him I
was at a bar the bartender looked at the
Hat said nothing a guy ordered a drink
uh
the drink was made it was almost like
the the people I see with the Maga hats
in New York City
they almost seem underwhelmed that
nobody is reacting to them now can you
find instances of someone with a Maga
hat or someone with a Biden hat being uh
aggrieved I'm sure you can but the idea
that you're particularly unsafe in New
York City with a Maga hat give me a
break these people live in a fantasy
world it's just pathetic
um Echo icon says bless your heart you
look like you've been vaccinated how can
you tell is it that I'm functioning this
is the sort of bottom of the barrel
stuff but I look like I've been
vaccinated that's the new by the way the
the new sort of like alpha male sort of
thing getting vaccinated means you're
afraid to deal with the illness yourself
and you're caught it's sort of like
calling for your mommy this is the
dumbest analogy to vaccination that I've
maybe maybe ever heard but there's a lot
of dumb people here hey this is cool
Rosie O'Donnell yes that Rosie O'Donnell
who has actually been a follower of the
David Pacman show for a long time friend
of the show Rosie O'Donnell would love
to appear on her podcast if she's
interested
um commenting about Dianne Feinstein
and says about Dianne Feinstein sad
someone tell her it's time to bow out
with gratitude with gratitude so there
is Rosie O'Donnell with a very powerful
declaration we hear from her often
actually it's a beautiful thing all
right a couple comments from Facebook
Hubert Wisniewski says even if
Republicans do choose DeSantis as their
candidate
Donald will still run for president he
still has to he has no choice because
he's hoping that saves him from going to
jail
my hope I am not a Praying person
but after my prayers were recently
answered for there to be Tech glitches
during Ron desantis's campaign launch I
now am like wow maybe prayer does work
so I think now I have to shift my prayer
to hoping that somehow Des sanctimonious
Ron de sanctimonious that hopefully he
does win the Republican primary and that
Trump runs third party because it will
be the end of Republican chances in 2024
as we know them I hope Hubert is correct
about that
and then Eric Johnson Eric Johnson
commented on Facebook's says I think
these fines slash penalties need to
immediately be put in some escrow or
whatever kind of account so Trump can't
hide it spend it whatever while all
appeals are exhausted until the money is
actually taken away from trump it won't
be real to him I agree with this this is
in reference to the five million dollars
that failed former president Trump has
been ordered to pay Eugene Carroll
because he was found liable for both
sexual assault and defamation against
her and Trump was ordered to pay five
million dollars he's appealing it and so
what Eric is correctly pointing out and
it's something many of us have discussed
sure Trump's been ordered to pay but
until he pays we shouldn't assume that e
Gene Carroll is going to see even a
dollar of that money I believe it would
be great to sequester that money escrow
it immediately I have no belief that
that is actually what's happening and at
this point I certainly can't tell you
that I'm confident that Donald Trump is
actually going to pay out I hope he does
I hope Eugene Carroll's lawyers are
ready to do what needs to be done to get
that money
but I am until I see the money
I am going to be skeptical that it is
coming all right you can email info
davidpackman.com you can make a comment
on YouTube Facebook who knows what's
going to show up in the Friday feedback
segment and of course remember that
everything we do is supported so
strongly so directly by people like you
who go to joinpakman.com and they get
themselves a beautiful membership thank
your lucky stars every day you're not
Dave Pacman you don't have to be me
to get a membership and get access to
the bonus show sign up at joinpakman.com
bonus show is coming up right after this
otherwise I'll see you back here on
Monday